.
An der Costa Blanca
ist Auswanderer Ralf Waldburger
nach neun Monaten nicht mehr gewohnt,
früh aufzustehen.
Es ist das allererste Mal
in meinem Leben,
dass ich verschlafen habe.
Heute ist ...
... ein wichtiger Tag für mich.
In der letzten Folge
kamen Ralf und Corinne
mit ihrer Hundepension nicht voran.
Die Baubewilligung fehlte.
Und die Nachbarn
wehrten sich dagegen.
Wenn es jetzt schon Probleme gibt,
sind diese
für die Zukunft vorprogrammiert.
Nach dem Lockdown in Ruanda
gingen die Bauarbeiten
im Fitnessklub von Dianne Schommer
weiter.
Es kommt besser als gedacht.
Ihr Mann Marco liess Zitronengras
anpflanzen - als zweites Standbein.
Aufs ganze Jahr gesehen gibt es
Ertrag. Man liegt immer zurück.
Das Projekt mit dem Wasserturm
in Cuxhaven verzögerte sich weiter.
Anstatt im eigenen Café
hoch über der Stadt
verkauften die Caboussats
ihre Getränke auf dem Wochenmarkt.
# Uf u dervo.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
(Dianne, Kinyarwanda)
Im Fitnessstudio von Dianne Schommer
ist immerhin der Geräteräum
schon fast fertig.
18 gebrauchte Fitnessmaschinen
haben die Auswanderer
im Hochseecontainer
nach Ruanda verschifft.
Cardio ist mein Bereich.
Aber das hier ...
Das ist für Bodybuilder.
Für die Beine und so ...
Es wird jemanden geben,
der dafür zuständig ist.
Das ist mein Zuständigkeitsbereich.
Crosstrainer, Crosstrainer ...
Und ... das ist wie ein Velo.
Es hat noch eine Rückenstütze.
Die Geräte stammen aus einem
Fitnessklub im Kanton Solothurn.
Dort war Dianne viele Jahre
als Zumba-Trainerin angestellt.
In Ruanda ist die 50-Jährige
jetzt Chefin
ihres eigenen kleinen Sportstudios.
In zehn Tagen
soll auch der Kursraum fertig sein.
Nächsten Freitag sollte es gut sein.
Der Raum sollte fertig sein.
Geputzt, mit fertigem Boden ...
Wir werden
noch mehr Licht installieren.
Aber sonst ...
Ich hoffe,
dass der Raum am Freitag bereit ist.
Eröffnen kann Dianne
trotzdem noch nicht.
Der Betrieb von Fitnessklubs
ist wegen der Corona-Krise
bis auf Weiteres verboten.
* Piepen *
Ein wenig ausserhalb von Kigali
hat Ehemann Marco einen weiteren
Termin in Sachen Zitronengras.
(Marco, Englisch)
Nicolas Hitimana ist Chef eines
Unternehmens, das Duftöl herstellt.
Er überlegt,
die erste Ernte von Marco zu kaufen.
Bald zeigt sich, ob es sich
gelohnt hat, es anzupflanzen.
Ich bin etwas unter Druck.
Für den Verkauf
muss die Qualität des Grases stimmen.
Je höher der Zitrusanteil ist,
desto mehr Geld bekommt Marco.
(Marco, Englisch)
Hm.
(Nicolas, Englisch)
Okay.
Bei guter Qualität könnte Marco rund
1'000 $ für die erste Ernte erzielen.
Ich habe mit mehr gerechnet.
Aber diese Pflanze wächst wieder,
nachdem sie geschnitten wurde.
Man kann sie
alle drei bis vier Monate ernten.
Es wächst von alleine.
(Marco)
Nicolas ist noch unschlüssig.
Vor dem Kauf möchte er eine Probe
des Grases im Labor analysieren.
* Heitere Musik *
* Bellen *
Endlich Hundegebell
auf dem Grundstück
von Corinne und Ralf Waldburger
an der Costa Blanca.
Hund Benji erobert sein neues Reich.
* Bellen *
Ralfs Sohn Mischa hat den Spitz
in die Obhut seines Vaters gegeben.
In der Schweiz hatte Mischa
zu wenig Zeit für das Tier.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Ich lasse offen, Schatz.
Ginge es
nach den beiden Auswanderern,
würden sie jetzt bereits
die Vierbeiner ihrer Kunden betreuen.
Doch die Hundepension
unter spanischer Sonne
ist noch immer
ein weit entfernter Traum.
So wie die Touristen fehlt auch die
Baubewilligung ― schon seit Monaten.
Das ist ja riesig!
- Ja.
Es grande.
Bis die Bewilligung da ist,
holen sie Offerten
für den Bau ihrer Hundepension ein.
(Leise)
Sag ihm, er soll mit dir sprechen.
Ja.
(Corinne)
(Verkäufer)
Anstatt einer Mauer zum Nachbarn
zu bauen,
wollen sie das Gebäude
mit Lärmschutzplatten verkleiden.
(Verkäufer)
Müssen es Türen sein oder nicht?
- Nein. Man könnte Schieber ...
(Verkäufer)
Sì.
- Und ...
Mit einem Seil.
So kann man es öffnen.
So.
- Ah. Ahì.
* Sie lacht. *
Es ... puerta.
Vale.
Muy bien.
Es ist so,
wie ich es mir vorgestellt habe.
Auch die Art der Konstruktion.
Es ist teilweise
sogar besser als gedacht.
Ja, stimmt.
- Es ist eine gute Sache.
Muchas gracias.
* Heitere Musik *
Gut 200 km von Cuxhaven entfernt
liegt der Ort,
wo neue Pläne von Alain und
Mirabelle Caboussat Gestalt annehmen.
Hier, in einer Werkstatt,
lassen sie ihren Citroen HY
zum Kaffeemobil umbauen.
Hallo.
Hallo, Krim.
- Hallo.
Wir sind fast pünktlich.
Das wird aber knapp.
Ja, aber es geht schon.
Den neuen Kühlschrank
soll Mechaniker Krim in den Oldtimer
der Emmentaler einbauen.
Vorsicht.
Eigentlich
war es ein alter Wasserturm,
der Alain und seine Frau Mirabelle
dazu bewegte,
nach Norddeutschland
auszuwandern.
Doch weil sich der Umbau des Turmes
immer mehr verzögert,
suchen sie nun
eine neue Einnahmequelle.
Sehr gut.
- Da ist das gute Stück.
Wunderbar.
Mirabelle, bitte schön.
Den Wagen hatten die Caboussats
bei ihrem Umzug an die Nordsee
mitgebracht.
Auf Flohmärkten wollte Alain
daraus sein Lego verkaufen.
Ja. Sie haben gearbeitet.
Die Elektroinstallationen
wurden gemacht.
Wie gefällt dir der Boden?
- Gut.
Das ist gut.
- Tipptopp.
Ich kann sogar stehen.
- Ja.
Du wärst ungefähr dort.
Noch etwas weiter zu mir.
Und die Kaffeemühle ist hier.
Hier sind die Geräte.
- Genau.
Wenn ich hier rausschaue,
strecke ich meinen Po ...
Das sind 40 cm.
Du kannst etwas näher ran.
Zieh den Hintern nach vorne.
Als Nächstes verkleidet
Mechaniker Krim die Innenwände.
Wie genau, darüber sind sich
die Caboussats aber noch nicht einig.
Schatz, wenn wir das so hintun,
würde der Tresen bis hierhin kommen.
Mit Abdichtung ...
- Es gefällt mir nicht.
Ich sage es ganz klar.
Es ist eine Holzimitation.
Das andere ist auch Holz.
Das passt nicht zusammen.
Das ist Nussbaum. Das andere auch.
Das andere ist eine Platte,
die zugeschnitten werden muss.
Dann haben wir eine Fläche.
Das wird mit einer Fuge abgedichtet.
Einen Cappuccino, bitte.
Ich sehe schon.
Wir kommen nicht zu einem Ergebnis.
Ihr wollt mich unbedingt überzeugen.
Nein,
diese Struktur und der Tresen ...
Es sollte das gleiche Material sein.
Es braucht noch etwas Zeit,
aber schlussendlich
wird sich Mirabelle durchsetzen.
(Englisch)
* Jubel *
In Kigali bereitet Dianne
die zukünftigen Coaches
auf die Arbeit im Fitnessklub vor.
Es ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Ich bin noch nicht bereit.
Aber das kommt noch.
Ich muss noch einige Sachen lernen.
Ich war bisher Mitarbeiterin.
Und jetzt bin ich "Chefin".
Aber beim Sport ist alles okay.
Wir sind locker.
* Mitreissende elektronische Musik *
Let's go! Let's go!
Hey!
Three!
Jump, jump, jump!
* Jubel *
Schnuckel,
ich dehne und klinke mich aus.
Ich brauche noch Zeit.
- Ja.
Dianne träumte schon seit Jahren
von einem eigenen Fitnessstudio.
In Ruanda
kann sie diesen Wunsch verwirklichen.
Marco unterstützt sie dabei,
so gut er kann.
Da sind wir wieder.
Ausserdem versucht er, weitere
Einnahmequellen zu erschliessen.
Mittlerweile
hat der Maschinebauingenieur
sein erstes Mandat abgeschlossen.
Im Auftrag einer Stiftung
erstellte der 52-Jährige
ein Ausbildungskonzept
für die ruandische Regierung.
Und ein Folgeauftrag
ist auch schon da.
Im Bereich Beratung und wenn es
um die Berufsausbildung geht,
um die Vorbereitung,
ist Corona kein Hindernis.
Beim Zitronengras
ist es ganz anders.
Da sind die Preise zusammengekracht.
Oder das Lifestyle-Fitnesscenter,
das wir noch immer nicht
eröffnen können.
Beruflich fasst Marco
in Ruanda langsam Fuss.
Doch mit seinem Herzen
ist er noch nicht ganz angekommen
in der neuen Heimat.
Tschüss.
Gehen wir zu den Jasskollegen.
Ja, schon gut.
Viel Spass.
- Danke.
Jetzt ist bei mir Mandela-Zeit.
Mandela.
# Free Nelson Mandela.
Alle paar Wochen trifft Marco
ein paar andere Schweizer zum Jassen.
See you.
Einen Schieber zu jassen
ist für Marco mehr als ein Spiel.
Es hilft ihm auch ein wenig,
sein Heimweh zu lindern.
Ich vermisse die Schweiz -
nach sechs Monaten.
V.a. meinen Sohn.
Meinen Sohn, meinen Freund.
Und meinen Bruder.
Manchmal würde ich einfach gerne
für drei Wochen wegfliegen.
Danach würde es wieder gehen.
Ich war noch nie länger
in meinem Leben von zu Hause weg.
Es macht mir mehr aus
als zuvor gedacht.
* Melancholische Musik *
Grüezi miteinander.
Wow.
Ça va?
Ça roule.
- Ça roule.
Heute treffen sie sich bei André.
Er besass eine Baufirma und
lebt schon seit 40 Jahren in Ruanda.
Ein modernes Haus.
- Alles per Container gekommen.
Solche Sachen
kann man hier nicht kaufen.
Das wollte ich sagen.
Ein Haus wie bei uns.
Wie in der Schweiz.
Das ist gut.
Du hast es schön hier.
Schön, schön.
Ah, oui, désolé.
- Non, non.
Schaufeln.
- Schaufeln?
Also, Schaufeln.
Regelmässig Karten spielte Marco
letztmals in der Kantonsschule.
Jassen ist ein kleines Stück Heimat.
Auch wieder Schweizerdeutsch
zu hören, oder Französisch.
Ich muss spielen, nicht?
Ich komme.
Dann spielen wir das hier aus.
* Klimpernde Musik *
An der Costa Blanca
ist der Sommer eingekehrt.
Der strenge Lockdown ist vorbei.
Die heissen Temperaturen lassen
das Coronavirus fast vergessen.
Für die Auswanderer in Benissa
ist die Zeit gekommen,
eine neue Idee umzusetzen.
Sie wollen ihr Poolhaus vermieten:
an Feriengäste mit Hund.
Denn seit Corinne und Ralf
in Spanien sind,
verdienen sie kein Geld.
Damit sich die Kunden wohlfühlen,
haben sie die Zweizimmerwohnung
renoviert,
eine Klimaanlage installiert
und die Küchenzeile
mit neuen Geräten ausgestattet.
Wir hatten ein kleineres Problem.
Der Kühlschrank war zu weit hinten.
Jetzt geht die Tür nicht mehr auf.
Zwischen 350 und 950 Euro pro Woche
wollen sie verlangen -
je nach Saison.
Das sieht toll aus.
Kein Problem mehr.
Auch mit dem Baugesuch
für das Hundehotel
sind sie ein kleines Stück weiter.
Der Antrag hat eine Hürde in
der spanischen Bürokratie genommen.
Als Nächstes muss der Veterinär
der Provinz sein Okay geben.
Weniger gut läuft es
mit den Nachbarn der Waldburgers.
Ein Witz.
Unsere lieben Nachbarn
haben einer Zeitung mitgeteilt,
dass hier
ein Hundehotel gebaut wird.
Die Nachbarschaft
werde dadurch beeinträchtigt.
Sie schreiben,
es würden Zwinger erbaut,
in die sie ihren Hund
nicht bringen würden.
Das stimmt nicht.
- Nein. Wir bauen keine Zwinger.
Man schiesst über die Medien
auf uns, anstatt mit uns zu reden.
Man macht sich Gedanken.
Wollen wir überhaupt
so viel Geld investieren in etwas,
von dem wir am Ende nicht wissen,
ob wir alles genauso machen können,
wie wir das wollen?
Oder ist es immer ein Kampf?
* Bellen *
Kommst du auch?
Wieso bellst du?
Hast du die Nachbarn angebellt?
Ja, ja.
Als Zugezogene ohne Netzwerk
ist es schwierig,
sich gegen alteingesessene Nachbarn
zu wehren.
In Cuxhaven haben die Caboussats
einmal mehr Schwierigkeiten
mit ihrem Wasserturm.
Das Projekt mit dem Gästebetrieb
im Turm wird immer komplizierter.
Wir haben noch ein Parkplatzproblem.
Wir haben die Stadt gefragt,
ob wir dieses Land kaufen können.
Es wäre optimal für die Stellplätze,
die wir vorweisen müssen.
Die Parkplätze kämen aber
in den Wurzelbereich zweier Buchen.
Und die müssen geschützt werden.
Man muss so weit wie die Äste gehen.
Von hier an.
Bis hier muss
eine Wurzelbrücke gemacht werden.
Nicht weiter hinten,
sondern eher weiter vorne.
Es braucht den gesamten Teil
als Wurzelbrücke.
Das sind 127 m2, also ca. 130 m2.
Für sechs Parkplätze müssten wir
einen derart grossen Platz kaufen.
Den müssten wir unterhalten.
Das kostet weit über 100'000.
Man fragt sich, ob das sinnvoll ist.
Da hat es viele Brombeeren.
Daraus machen wir Konfitüre.
- Schau.
Anstatt eigene Parkplätze zu bauen,
könnten Alain und Mirabelle der
Stadt eine Ablösegebühr bezahlen.
Dann hätten sie aber keine
Abstellplätze für ihre Kunden.
Und diese bräuchten sie eigentlich.
Denn oben im Wassertank wollen
die Caboussats ein Café eröffnen,
dazu ein Bed and Breakfast
betreiben.
Die Idee, im Turm zu wohnen,
haben sie unterdessen aufgeben,
denn das Vorhaben wird immer teurer.
Und die Planung stockt -
seit bald zwei Jahren.
Was hier teilweise demoliert wurde,
stammt von einem Gutachten -
da wurden Materialproben gemacht.
Solche Analysen
kosten Tausende Euro.
Es musste abgeklärt werden,
ob Bomben aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
in der Nähe sind.
Das ist nicht der Fall.
Aber es kostet alles.
Selbst das Treppenhaus des 120 Jahre
alten Gebäudes wird zum Problem.
Es ist 4 cm zu wenig breit -
für den Fluchtweg.
Das Geländer
ist nach neusten Normen zu tief.
Und das Geländer ...
Hier sind zu grosse Löcher.
Ein Kind könnte herunterfallen.
Solche Sachen verkomplizieren
für uns das ganze Bauprojekt.
Alles ist möglich.
Aber es stellt sich natürlich
die Frage der Kosten.
Gründe für die Verzögerung
gibt es mittlerweile viele.
Die Emmentaler mussten Monate
auf Termine mit Gutachtern warten.
Sie erhielten
zusätzliche Auflagen der Behörden.
Und unterschiedliche Vorstellungen
zwischen Caboussats
und ihren Architekten machten
die Sache auch nicht einfacher.
Es ist mühsam.
Deshalb haben wir die Kaffeebar.
Wir wollen etwas machen.
Sonst würden wir dauernd
daran denken. Das geht nicht.
Wir haben genügend andere Sachen
daneben aufgebaut.
Das ist unser Hauptprojekt. Aber es
geht nicht voran. Das ist scheisse.
Spinnweben.
Mirabelle und Alain haben eigentlich
alles richtig gemacht.
Vor dem Kauf des Turms im Jahr 2017
hatten sie sich
von Experten beraten lassen,
die die Pläne
auf Machbarkeit überprüften.
Man kann nicht alles wissen.
Man kann viel machen.
Vieles ist möglich.
Es gab Vorabklärungen.
Aber alles kann man nicht machen.
Das ist unmöglich.
Vielleicht waren wir zu euphorisch.
Wir dachten, zwei Jahre genügen.
Jetzt sind wir im vierten Jahr.
So ist es.
Es zeichnet die Caboussats aus,
dass sie nicht einfach aufgeben.
Gemeinsam halten sie weiter
an ihren grossen Plänen fest.
Ohne das Hundehotel fehlt
den Auswanderern an der Costa Blanca
nicht nur das Einkommen,
sondern auch eine Aufgabe.
Tag für Tag müssen sie sich aufs Neue
selber beschäftigen.
Bald ein Jahr ist es her, dass Ralf
seinen letzten Arbeitstag hatte.
In einem Autohaus im Thurgau
war der 50-Jährige
Chef über das Ersatzteillager.
In Spanien
erhoffte er sich mehr Zeit im Alltag.
Jetzt hat er zu viel davon.
Ehefrau Corinne war Sachbearbeiterin
in einem Industriebetrieb.
Der Wunsch, mit Tieren zu arbeiten,
und die Sehnsucht nach schönem Wetter
motivierte die 48-Jährige,
in den Süden auszuwandern.
Es ist keine einfache Zeit.
Wir sitzen 24 Std. aufeinander.
Früher hatte jeder seinen Job.
Jeder war tagsüber beschäftigt.
Jetzt sitzen wir hier und schauen,
was wir tun können.
Es ist nicht einfach,
wenn man keine Beschäftigung hat
oder nichts machen kann.
Das belastet ihn im Moment sehr.
* Sanfte Musik *
So lange nicht
vorwärtsmachen zu können
ist für Ralf, den Macher,
besonders bitter.
Puh.
Kann ich dich dabei unterstützen?
Nein.
Die muss aber irgendwie raus.
Wie willst du das machen?
- Hacken, hacken, hacken.
So.
Yeah. Super.
Puh.
- Das hast du super gemacht.
* Ächzen *
Wenn Herausforderungen
zu gross werden,
hilft häufig ein wenig Abstand,
um die Dinge
aus der Ferne neu zu betrachten.
Mirabelle und Alain
sind nach Lüneburg gereist.
Sie wollen sich beraten lassen.
Denn hier steht
ein denkmalgeschützter Wasserturm -
ähnlich alt
wie der Turm der Caboussats.
Vor gut 20 Jahren
wurde er komplett umgebaut.
Wir müssen uns Gedanken machen,
wie es weitergeht.
Wir erhoffen uns Impulse.
Für sie war es auch umständlich -
mit Brandschutzbehörden
und Denkmalpflege.
Es ist sicher gut, das aus einer
anderen Perspektive zu betrachten.
Es ist wahnsinnig schön.
- Und gross.
Wie ein Schlösschen.
Das 56 m hohe Gebäude
ist Aussichtsturm,
Museum und Veranstaltungsort
in einem.
Das ist schön.
Das ist ...
Wir haben auch eine tolle Aussicht.
Aber nicht draussen.
Manfred Koplin vom Trägerverein
zeigt den Schweizern den Turm.
Von hier aus
sieht man die drei Stadtkirchen.
Sie gehören
zu den Wahrzeichen der Stadt -
wie auch der Wasserturm.
Wir sind froh, dass wir den Wasser-
turm umbauen und erhalten konnten.
Das muss ich fotografieren.
Das muss ich zeigen.
Es geht um die Idee.
Wie im Turm der Caboussats ist der
ehemalige Wassertank das Herzstück.
Es ist genial, im Tank zu stehen
und dieses Gefühl erleben zu können.
Es ist faszinierend.
Aber wenn hier
ein Feuer ausbrechen würde,
würde der Rauch
auch hier aufsteigen.
Natürlich. Das zieht nach oben.
Und bei uns
machen sie ein grosses Geschiss.
Dann dürfte man nicht
auf den Eiffelturm
oder den Fernsehturm in Berlin.
Man dürfte keinen Turm begehen.
Das weiss aber jede Bauaufsicht.
Da muss man abwägen.
Man muss Risiken abwägen
und Entscheidungen treffen.
Entscheidet man falsch, kann man
keinen solchen Turm betreiben.
Die Tendenz ist,
dass man sich komplett
aus der Verantwortung ziehen möchte.
Man will sich
für alle Eventualitäten absichern,
damit auch sicher niemand
belangt werden könnte.
Das ist hier zwei, drei Jahre lang
auch so gewesen.
Die Verantwortlichen hielten sich
nur an Recht und Gesetz.
Das hat sich dann
zum Glück geändert.
Ich hoffe auch,
dass ein Umdenken stattfindet,
damit erkannt wird,
dass genhandelt werden muss.
Längerfristig verkommt er.
Der Umbau in Lüneburg dauerte
drei Jahre und kostete 6 Mio. Euro -
weit mehr, als die Caboussats für
ihren Wasserturm kalkuliert haben.
Zuerst haben wir gedacht,
dass hier unsere Wohnung sein wird.
Da wird jetzt
eine Hochzeitssuite gemacht.
Auf diesen zwei Ebenen
wird das Café sein.
Hier der Personalraum.
Und dann die Hotelzimmer
bis hierher.
Im Erdgeschoss sind Gewerberäume.
Unser Konzept ist sehr ähnlich.
Haben Sie schon Mittel eingesetzt
oder stehen Sie noch am Anfang?
Diese Frage stellt sich im Moment.
Wie können wir weitergehen?
Ich lege Ihnen die Deutsche
Stiftung Denkmalschutz ans Herz.
Ja. Da sind wir schon dran.
Dann gibt das Amt
für regionale Landesförderung.
Das sitzt in Lüneburg, ist
aber auch für Cuxhaven zuständig.
Das sollte man anfragen,
welche Förderungen es gibt.
Das Projekt steht und fällt also
mit solchen Sachen.
Mit Netzwerk und Fördergeldern
werden Caboussats
ihr Projekt eher stemmen können.
Im Fitnessstudio der Schommers
in Kigali
verlegen die Arbeiter endlich
den Fussboden.
600 Kunststofffliessen
haben Dianne und Marco aufgetrieben -
nach langer Suche.
Hi.
Tity, der zukünftige Chefinstruktor
der Sportstudios,
behält die Arbeiten
für die Schommers im Auge.
(Englisch)
Der chinesische Klebstoff, den sie
mit den Fliessen gekauft haben,
hält nicht wie erhofft.
Jetzt haben die Arbeiter
einen neuen Kleber organisiert.
Es ist gut,
dass der Boden endlich drin ist.
Ob er hält, werden wir sehen.
In seinem neuen Leben
muss sich Marco von der gewohnten
Schweizer Präzision verabschieden
und sich mit dem Machbaren
zufriedengeben.
Ich habe mich langsam daran gewöhnt,
dass es nicht immer so läuft
wie gewünscht.
Vielleicht bin ich im Moment
noch zu nachgiebig.
Vielleicht akzeptiere ich zu viel.
Aber es wird langsam
ein Fitnesscenter.
Es ist kein Saal mehr,
in dem Parteisitzungen
oder Hochzeiten stattfinden.
Gut fünf Monate
dauert der Umbau bereits -
viel länger, als die Schommers
ursprünglich dachten.
Aha, so geht das.
Hm.
* Ächzen *
Scheisse.
Wenn es die Corona-Situation erlaubt,
können sie ihr Fitnessstudio
bald eröffnen.
An der Costa Blanca muss Auswanderer
Ralf für einmal früh raus.
Es ist das allererste Mal
in meinem Leben,
dass ich verschlafen habe.
Heute ist ...
... ein wichtiger Tag für mich.
Ralf hat eine neue Geschäftsidee.
Heute ist dafür das erste Treffen.
* Bellen *
* Er spricht unverständlich. *
Tschüss, bis später.
- Tschüss.
Tschüss.
Ich habe eines Abends
mit einem Freund diskutiert.
Ich sagte ihm,
ich müsse etwas machen,
ich könne nicht länger
bloss rumsitzen und warten,
bis wir die Bewilligung
für das Hundehotel erhalten.
Er fragte mich,
was ich denn gerne mache.
Ich sagte, ich würde gerne Gärten
pflegen und Gebäude unterhalten.
Er sagte, es gebe hier so viele
leer stehende Ferienhäuser.
Die Leute bräuchten jemanden,
der ihr Haus betreut.
Ralf möchte sich
als Hauswart selbstständig machen.
Dafür hat er sich
mit einer Immobilien-Bewirtschafterin
verabredet.
Sie hat sich bereit erklärt,
ihm einen Tag lang
Einblick ins Geschäft zu gewähren.
Wir sind da.
Ralf ist am Treffpunkt -
knapp 5 Min. zu spät.
Die Kundschaft
schätzt Pünktlichkeit.
Ich weiss. Aber genau heute ...
- Ein Anruf wäre nett.
Genau heute ... Tja.
Ich hätte früher losfahren müssen.
Legen wir los.
Immobilien-Bewirtschafterin Dora
ist ebenfalls ausgewandert
und betreut mit ihrem Mann
mehrere Ferienhäuser.
Dieser Pool ist sehr grün.
Sie waren zwei Jahre nicht hier.
- Okay.
Gut.
Ich habe einmal vergessen,
abzuschliessen.
Prompt war eine Ratte drin.
Man muss also
wegen der Viecher aufpassen.
Da muss man
vielleicht zweimal durch.
Das mache ich.
- Einfach rundum.
Ich lasse jeweils das Wasser laufen.
Die oberste Stufe
muss mit Wasser bedeckt sein.
Ja.
Die oberste Stufe.
- Das mache ich zu Hause auch.
Ich kann das auch
bei anderen Pools machen.
Der hier ist etwas gar grün.
Meiner ist nie so grün.
Ob Poolpflege,
Gartenarbeit oder Hausbetreuung -
Ralf setzt darauf,
dass er mit seiner Idee
einer Rund-um-Betreuung
zahlungskräftige Kunden findet.
Wir hoffen immer noch, dass
das Hundehotel irgendwann anläuft,
wenn wir die Bewilligung bekommen.
Das ist eine Ergänzung.
Es geht mir hauptsächlich darum,
etwas zu tun, an dem ich Spass habe.
Das ist auch wichtig.
Die neue Aufgabe
scheint Ralf gut zu tun.
Als Nächstes
möchte er eine Webseite aufsetzen.
1'800 km nördlich
bereiten sich die Caboussats
auf ein wichtiges Gespräch vor.
Natürlich geht es
um ihren Wasserturm.
Wir gehen zum Oberbürgermeister.
Er wurde letzten November
neu gewählt.
Wir werden unser Anliegen anbringen
und aufzeigen,
wo die Schwierigkeiten sind und
weshalb wir nicht vorwärtskommen.
Wir möchten diese Themen ansprechen.
Einerseits wollen wir
die Fördergelder ansprechen.
Die Politik muss mithelfen.
Wir können nicht einfach zu einem
Eurorat gehen und Geld beantragen.
Das braucht Unterstützung
von der Stadt.
In dem Sinne
ist es mein letzter Versuch.
Wir wollen schauen, dass wir mit
einer Zusammenarbeit weiterkommen.
Mal schauen,
ob er uns eine Plattform bietet.
Wochenlang
haben sie auf den Termin gewartet.
Jetzt hoffen Alain und Mirabelle,
dass sie den neuen Oberbürgermeister
von ihrem Projekt überzeugen können.
Hallo. Guten Morgen.
Herzlich willkommen.
Hier eine Kleinigkeit aus
der Schweiz für Ihre Kaffeepause.
Danke.
Oberbürgermeister Uwe Santjer
und Baudezernent Martin Adamski
haben eine knappe Stunde Zeit
für die Caboussats und ihr Projekt.
Ich finde es gut,
dass wir uns heute treffen.
Wir sind froh, dass Sie da sind
und dass Sie mit Ihrer Initiative
den Wasserturm wiederbeleben wollen.
Es ist ein historisches Gebäude.
Meine Mutter
hat darin den Krieg überlebt.
Dieser Turm weckt viele Emotionen.
Es ist schön, dass Sie
den Mut haben, das anzugehen
und mit Ihrer Art einen neuen
Blickwinkel nach Cuxhaven bringen.
Vielen Dank. Das Projekt
bestimmt grösstenteils unser Leben.
Wir brauchen Unterstützung.
Ohne geht es nicht.
Bei der Fassade
sind wir daran interessiert,
dass wir mit der Stadt
etwas machen können.
Auch die Fenster.
Es hat über 100 Fenster.
Herr Tietz möchte,
dass es Holzfenster werden.
Holzfenster kosten über 65'000 Euro
mehr als Kunststofffenster.
Beim Dach muss man
das Geländer innen anschauen.
Es muss vieles gemacht werden.
Aber wir können uns
nicht alles leisten.
Das können wir nachvollziehen.
Es gab einen ersten Impuls
der Wirtschaftsförderung.
Das werden wir angehen.
Beim Brandschutz
gibt es nicht viel Spielraum.
Das werden wir abklopfen.
Bei den Fenstern wird es bleiben.
Aber wir schauen, dass wir es
mit Fördergeldern hinkriegen,
dass die Belastung zumutbar ist.
Das Gespräch
verläuft vielversprechend.
Aber gelingt es
den Caboussats tatsächlich,
die Stadt mit ins Boot zu holen?
In Ruanda sind weitere sechs Wochen
ins Land gezogen.
Sechs Wochen,
in denen sich viel verändert hat.
Die Schommers haben beim Fitnessclub
neue Nachbarn:
eine Autotuning-Werkstatt.
Es gibt dem Ort etwas mehr Klasse.
Wir sind nicht dagegen,
dass hier etwas anderes ist.
Aber die Art und Weise ...
Unser Schild wurde einfach auf die
Seite ... Es wurde runtergenommen.
Wir haben aber zurückgeschlagen.
Wir haben jetzt
ein grosses Schild an der Mauer.
Jetzt haben wir eine Ecke ...
Man sieht uns jetzt relativ gut.
Das Rot-Grau
hebt sich gut vom Schwarz ab -
zumindest wenn man von hier kommt.
Längst ist der Umbau abgeschlossen,
und auch der Boden ist fertig.
Alles wäre bereit.
Aber eröffnen dürfen die Schommers
immer noch nicht.
Dabei sah alles gut aus. Über Wochen
waren die Corona-Fallzahlen tief.
Die Regierung
kündigte Lockerungen an.
Die Schommers rechneten fest damit,
bald starten zu können.
Doch plötzlich schossen
die Neuinfektionen wieder in die Höhe
und das Fitnessstudio
muss weiter geschlossen bleiben.
Heute haben wir eine
nicht so gute Nachricht erhalten.
Ich bin entsetzt.
Ich bin so traurig.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie es jetzt weitergeht.
Aber wir putzen jetzt die Maschinen.
Dann möchte ich sie zudecken,
damit sie nicht verstauben.
Ich weisst nicht,
wann es weitergeht.
Langsam wird es schwierig
mit dem Vermieter.
Der Vermieter
möchte irgendwann Geld sehen.
Im Vertrag steht,
wann wir eröffnen sollten.
Es ist verständlich,
wenn er irgendwann sagt ...
Es kann nicht ewig nichts verdienen.
Er hat auch schon angedeutet, dass
er unsere Anzahlung zurückbezahlt
und aus dem Vertrag aussteige.
Er möchte anderweitig vermieten.
Heute ist wirklich kein guter Tag.
Wir überlegen uns,
ob Dianne für zwei, drei Wochen
in die Schweiz zurückgeht.
(Mit gebrochener Stimme)
Um Dylan zu sehen.
Ja.
Oder du.
- Ich kann nicht.
Ich bin der Einzige,
der etwas verdienen wird.
Ja.
* Schwermütige Klänge *
Die Zukunft der Schommers mit ihrem
Fitnessstudio bleibt weiter ungewiss.
In der nächsten Folge
von "Auf und davon" kommt Sohn Dylan
für ein Spiel mit der National-
mannschaft überraschend nach Ruanda.
Aber die Schommers dürfen ihren Sohn
wegen Corona
nicht in die Arme schliessen.
Wir konnten ihn wenigstens sehen.
Haben Sie das
mit dem Kärcher gemacht?
Die Waldburgers
haben ihren ersten Einsatz
als Immobilien-Bewirtschafter.
In Sachen Hundehotel aber bekommen
sie unerfreuliche Neuigkeiten.
Nach über einem Jahr heisst es,
dass die Eingabe zu umfangreich ist.
In Cuxhaven machen die Caboussats
ihr neues Kaffeemobil
bereit für den ersten Einsatz.
- Prost.
Ausserdem beginnen Alain und Mira-
belle, den Wasserturm zu entkernen.
Wir müssen einfach mal loslegen.
# U si stige i Flüger,
flüge mit de Vögu furt
# und chöme nümme hei.
# U sie löh hie aues zrugg
uf dr Suechi für nes nöis Dahei.
# Si göh hüt nu uf u dervo.
# Uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Daniela Zacheo - 2021